merry christmas eve everyone we're
celebrating with lots of fun for you
tonight
including a special christmas edition
of supermarket showdown that's right
because you asked for it
our first ever holiday edition of
jessie's feeding frenzy
and of course my personal favorite the
greatest segment that ever was and will
ever be
in the history of segments animals are
great plus we'll do our secret santa
gift exchange
you don't want to miss our annual
tradition we invented it
but first we've been making a list and
checking it twice
so let's find out who's on the fives
naughty and
nice list look at that graphic spent a
lot of time on that one dana
all right dana uh i i i'm just
transfixed by juan's uh christmas eve
suit um but i'm gonna try to yeah you
know
you know who gave this to me this is
jesse's christmas
gift to me last year greg yeah and i
think it's a joke about you know
snowflake
lives yes but i actually like it so he
didn't he didn't think i would like it i
am frosty in my neighborhood
i think we found something worse you can
give someone besides covid
that suit
what is your naughty and nice list was
it hard for you to do a naughty list
no in fact i had to narrow it down i do
i did you know i noticed juan's outfit
and i also noticed yours
yours is not very festive okay my
naughty and nice list
my naughty and nice list is i went with
the chinese communist party
on the naughty list i think kind of for
obvious reasons for
unleashing this virus on the world for
being reckless
with global health and for the economic
pain that it has caused everyone
i'm just awful awful behavior
and then on the nice list i got i had a
chance to go to a food pantry
in new jersey um it's called the church
of epiphany
in brick new jersey and i met these
ladies there you can see them on the
screen
they volunteer every week they do two
distributions one on mondays and one on
saturdays
and they ask for no credit these are the
most humble women the whole time we were
there filming they never stopped working
i was super inspired by them and uh
thank them for what they do
oh that's nice and it's all volunteered
they're not there by force are they dana
no that would be on the naughty list
exactly just wanted to make that clear
because i would hate it
i would hate to find out later that you
were actually uh
promoting some kind of strange cult
all right one it is your turn
unless you want to discuss dana's well
actually actually i i thought that was
pretty cool i i think those people are
doing
really great work so hats off to them i
guess santa's hat if i had one
uh but on my naughty list i'm gonna go
for something that's
a little smaller than dana's uh joe
exotic
i think joe exotic and the whole idea of
mistreating
animals and making animals into sort of
toys uh not to be well treated not to be
abiding by their nature i think is just
wrong
and i just can't stand it and i hate to
even think about it because there are
people who
have exotic pets i hope they treat them
better than this and i hope they don't
put them on display in ways that
endanger their lives so to me
joe exotic belongs on the naughty list
this year
that's a good one what's your nice yeah
i think it's going to be
teachers greg i think teachers have had
to go through
really hard work in order to help our
kids stay up
this whole notion of virtual learning
going over the
uh ipads the social media effort it's
been very difficult it's difficult for
the kids but i think you've got to
understand
it to require the teachers to adapt to
changes
and of course it even includes what
you're seeing on the screen how to say
hello to kids without a hug and let them
know that you do care and that teachers
are there for them when they get back to
school
so for me a special special christmas
wish and blessing for teachers very good
all right now it's my turn my naughty
and nice list uh
let's do the naughties first these are
the uh poor man's abbott and costello
i think you know why they're on my
naughty list but let's roll
let's roll
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have mounted
on the front of your pretty face all
right here it is
the official re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out happens
do you think that you are an attractive
person now because you're
single and ready to mingle do you really
think you are some desirable
single person and that this is not just
people's pain
coming out of them i think
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
so is uh competence i guess because it's
you know he's the governor of new york
and you're
you're doing some comedy stick while
people are dying in your rest homes not
a good look
now my nice list uh it's kind of very
similar to dana she probably stole
my idea but i'm gonna give it to the
fundraiser
organizers and people like our um our
viewers at home
who reacted to these fun the the
fundraising like for example
um um when we when we mentioned uh
officer shea mccollonus who was shot
during a protest and paralyzed
we had mentioned in the five and that
raised i mean hundreds of thousands of
dollars
almost i think a million and then of
course paul and lydia
marino who were a couple that were
killed visiting their veteran son's
grave
um in a cemetery in delaware and we'd
mentioned it again
on the five and the money poured in to
help pay for the
the funerals and it was um it's really
amazing so i mean
the gofundme organization has made it
easier for people to do this
and the people that organize this out of
the goodness of their of their hearts
and then you guys at home who reacts and
just start
pulling out your money is it's something
really really special
so there you go who's next it's emily
hello emily
hello you all okay on my naughty list
heading it up is congress for their
continued incompetence and inability
to compromise on behalf of the american
people there is not enough coal
for that hill in my opinion and then in
terms of the nice list
heading it up for me is every small
business owner out there
and their families including and
especially my dad
that's him behind the counter of our
dairy winery there
and may santa and congress bring you all
everything that you need when are we
going to your winery
any time you're always welcome yeah
right
all right uh sorry jesse i can attest
i want to just say i can attest to the
quality of that wine it's quite good
me too all right jesse speaking of wine
what is your naughty and nice list
composed of
oh so my naughty list is hunter
obviously
and my nice list jesse waters tops that
and we'll begin with hunter it's obvious
from the escorts to the strippers to the
sex trafficking
to the drudge the the fighting of the
child support
he basically was responsible for getting
donald trump impeached with his
shenanigans in ukraine
and may be responsible for getting his
father impeached
in this new administration so hunter
takes the cake
and um hopefully by the time this airs
he's not behind bars
in terms of the nice list i maybe have
misread this segment
but i'm going to go with it i am going
to choose myself
and and i'm going to speak from the
heart here i think i had a great year
i was nice to my co-hosts i was uh
tender and and loving with regards to my
analysis
of people who i don't share their
political opinions
and i've matured as a person and i think
everybody recognizes that so
i go on the nice list there we go
you know the only way you could be on
the nice list was having hunter biden on
the naughty list
because just by the comparison okay you
win
all right
i'm gonna ask dana to hold my hand and
just squeeze it if i go down the wrong
path okay
if dana will virtually hold my hand here
am i doing okay so far no
okay dana didn't squeeze me sometimes i
feel like the sailor on the show
clinging for dear life
hoping someone to come and rescue me we
used to have a thing dana when i
was about to say something controversial
i would ask for you to hold my hand
and squeeze it i can't reach anymore i
have a solution
okay before i say something
controversial i'm gonna
squeeze my what do i call this
oh it was nice to look back and see us
all together like that around the table
maybe that'll happen one of these days
hopefully soon hopefully it will soon